welcome to the first session of
Wednesday our speaker is John to
Oppenheim and he's going to tell was how
the second one film that name is not any
quality but actually quality thanks for
Nana so I'd like to thank the local
organizers and the program committee for
the chance to present this work its
joint work with the UCL groups or Lewis
messiah's and two students are Beryl
Umbra and Chris Perry Chris is now at
the University of Copenhagen and Alvaro
al Umbra will be graduating shortly he's
a brilliant researcher and if anyone's
looking for a postdoc he'll be sure that
quickly the work we're presenting
appeared in kind of two publications
together in prx
I'll mostly be talking about the case of
fluctuating work rather than fluctuating
states I'm not presenting this work as
my contribution was significant but more
because my co-authors were too
embarrassed to present it but Alvaro and
Krista here and they'll answer any hard
questions
good so since we're friendly audience I
can probably show you this
it's a map by Rob speken and I guess the
general idea is that we can use tools in
information theory to understand lots of
different areas of physics and we've
heard about many of those different
topics throughout this conference I'm
particularly interested in understanding
thermodynamics so this little corner of
the map here it's a corner populated by
a number of different tribes they are
engaged in skirmishes where mostly they
reject each other's papers because their
paradigms are slightly different and I
guess the goal here was to in particular
well there's two I think communities of
the quantum information thermodynamics
community which uses tools from quantum
information theory and then alongside
that there's this big community will
call stochastic thermodynamics so people
that study things like the crooks
equation in the jet ski equation and the
two fields have kind of going along side
by side there have been some attempts to
bridge the gap but the goal here was to
understand the relationship between the
two fields
and of course once you can do that then
one's able to generalize their results
and extend them and extend them further
so that was the goal one of the main
goals of this project was to see the
relationship between these two different
fields along the way
we'll find some new results in major
ization theory and also see that our
results have application to finite time
thermodynamics so many of you but not
all of you were at Lydia Del Rio's
tutorial on thermodynamics so and you
probably all know of landau erasure but
just to quickly remind everyone
thermodynamics is a kind of information
theory there's a strong relationship and
it goes back to Maxwell Dillard and
especially Landauer and Bennett so for
example if we have a bit it's in an
unknown state then that's represent that
has to be represented physically and so
if we don't know what value the bit is
in and we want to erase it
then we're gonna have to physically do
that and Landauer said that that cost KT
log to bits of work so we for example
imagine a box with two partitions and an
atom inside the box if we want to erase
it we're gonna have to remove the
partition because we erasing it means we
put it in a zero state so on the left
here and so we need to push in the
piston and that costs KT log two bits of
worth good so I guess the question is
what do we mean by the first question we
can ask is what we mean by KT log two
bits of work and so let me ask you a few
questions about what we mean by KT log
two bits of work and let's go to the
limit of perfect erasure
so a small pop quiz in the morning so
what do you mean by the work is KT log
two I guess the question is how many of
these statements are true the first one
maybe is fairly easy the work is KT log
two an average but there will be
fluctuations around this value so how
many people think that one is true
and how many think it's false fusion
gets false okay I'm actually gonna treat
the quiz so that way people can answer
there because people don't see the
answering here
and then how many think that we can
achieve perfect ratio yeah the word
perfect is a giveaway isn't it and how
many think that if we use slightly more
than KT log tuba to work on average then
sometimes we'll actually gain some work
when we erase and people think that this
is true
few people thank you whole thing is
false
okay and no one put their hand maybe you
don't want to answer but maybe also we
don't know and that's I think the case
we don't actually know the answers to
these questions we sometimes know in the
case when we are only allowed reversible
operations but in general we don't know
the answer to the question and so this
work will answer some I think very basic
questions about land our ratio next
isn't maybe none of these statements are
true and this quiz is undecidable
the correct answer is actually it's not
either squizz is undecidable it's it's
just that the quiz is undecidable and
we'll be able to show that the first
three are false by by deriving this
relationship here so this is I think one
of the main at least classical results
of this paper I'm going to show you some
classical results and then I'm sure that
they follow some from some quantum
identities so the main result is this
one here and if you look at it it looks
a bit like the doubly sarcastic
condition that you're used to in many
aspects of major ization theory but it's
got an extra Gibbs factor here with some
funny W term there and that W is a
fluctuating work and what this set of
relationships are they're a
generalization of double stock assisity
to the case where you have fluctuating
work and we'll show that they arise in
the context of thermal thermodynamics
what that means if you have an arranger
process you're going to get two
equations which tell you what kinds of
value put constraints on the kinds of
work that you have and I'll go back to
this picture I'll come back to this
picture towards the end of the talk
so the main results that we'll present
is that we're going to look and see and
build a bridge to the field of
stochastic terminate thermodynamics
we'll be able to strengthen some of the
results there and learn some new things
we're gonna do that by generate by
generalizing the notion of doubly
stochastic maps and major ization one of
the results were able to drive is the
second law of thermodynamics as an
equality and we'll do that by introduced
introducing something called a
fine-grained free energy and later we'll
even see that there is a kind of a
quantum map which looks like a free
which helps to find a free energy and
operator and the main result is a fully
quantum identity which allows us to
derive very quickly in a line or to
various results from stochastic
thermodynamics if I have time I'll talk
about how we can go beyond this now that
we kind of have a framework for
understanding stochastic thermodynamics
we can use it to understand not just
fluctuations of work but also
fluctuations of states and we'll see
that it has some impact on some recent
results proving and quantifying the
third law of thermodynamics so just an
outline I'll review thermodynamics I'm
not going to do it I'll do it very
quickly because Lydia Del Rio did a nice
job of it in the tutorial but I know not
all of you were there and then I will
present these equalities for work
fluctuations all right so we're
interested in in how the work fluctuates
during a state transformation and then
I'll present the quantum identities
which give you these work fluctuations
and I'll end with some open questions
and kind of an overview of some of the
research directions we're going in
okay so you all probably know the three
dollars of thermodynamics a lot of you
earn computer scientists in computer
science so I don't take that as given
but the three dollars of the ranks
there's there's four of them and we're
interested in for the purposes of this
talk the second one the second law of
thermodynamics which as you probably
know is that if I have a cup of coffee
that's hot
in a cold room then it's very unlikely
that it's going to heat up so very
unlikely means we're talking about
quantities on average and it's also
important that we talk about a cyclic
process so we have some environment or
some heat bath and it returns back to
its original state
in the in the quantum regime it's
there's questions about what we mean by
a cyclic process which are unresolved
actually and you can quantify the third
law sorry the second law of
thermodynamics as an inequality so this
is the inequality that we'll later find
out can be derived from an equality and
it's just that the work has to be less
than a change in free energy so this is
about state transformations we can go
from one state wrote one state Sigma if
an oni if the work is less than the
change in free energy and the change the
free energy is just the average it's an
average quantity so it's the average
energy minus the temperature of the heat
bath that my system is in contact with
times the entropy and in this case we
use the von Neumann entropy but it could
also be a Shannon entropy and the for
reversible processes the work is just
the change in free energy exactly but
here we're interested also in
irreversible processes and then we have
an inequality so the work is strictly
the average work is strictly less and
what we're gonna find is that this
average inequality is just the first
order term of an inequality of an
equality which we Taylor expand
okay I don't mind questions by the way
if people have them so I think like a
lot of people when I learned
thermodynamics I was I didn't understand
very much about it and I think that was
largely because I was never in most
textbooks when you learn it as an
undergrad
you are never told what thermodynamics
is all right you just you know that
there's some ISO cores there's some idea
bats there's all kinds of isotherms and
you're never actually told what you're
allowed to do what the rules of the game
are so I think one of the things that
quantum information theory brings is we
first define this resource theory
approach where we first say the first
thing we need to do is we need to define
what thermodynamics is we need to say
what the rules of the game are
and these have been developed with
slight variations in them but I'll call
this one thermo operations it's the
following I have a I start off with the
density matrix Rho some state some
system row in state row with a
Hamiltonian HS I'm allowed to add some
free state alright it'll turn out that
this free state is the Gibbs State is
the thermal State so I'm allowed to put
my system in contact with some free
state that is just lying around and you
can in fact derive that it has to be the
thermal State or the theory becomes
trivial and next I'm allowed a work
system ok for the moment we'll just have
a I'll specify this in more detail in a
moment and then we want to put these all
into contact and there's lots of
different ways different paradigms in
different ways of doing it but the one
we're going to choose here is we're
going to allow energy conserving unit
Ares this is just like the first law of
thermodynamics so we're going to assume
that we have to the unitary has to
commute with the total Hamiltonian of
the system the reason we demand that it
seems like a very restrictive condition
but it's not actually the reason we
demand it is because we're interested in
work we're interested in how much energy
we need to perform a state
transformation and if we're interested
in energy then we have to make sure that
we account for all forms of energy and
we have to make sure that you don't
smuggle energy in so we want to make
sure that your operations conserve
energy which means that any energy which
is no longer in the system and bath must
have been transferred to the work
systems that way we get a proper
accounting for work we're allowed to
trace out for the purpose of this talk
I'm going to imagine it that I think
I'll imagine that the initial
Hamiltonian is the same as the final
Hamiltonian but we can actually easily
in our paper we deal with changing
hamiltonians so you can imagine the
final Hamiltonian is different to the
initial Hamiltonian you can account for
that just by adding a switch and finally
I'm going to assume that the operation
the unitary that we're doing is
translation invariant on the weight
and the reason I do that is the
following work is a process right it's
we can think of work as we have a weight
in the classical case and we want to
raise or lower it we want to do work on
the weight right we're on our system so
it's some sort of a process and in the
process we don't actually care where the
weight is initially what we what we care
about is how much we can lift it up by
right so we care about the differences
and so because we care about the
differences in height of the weight we
just only want it we want to make sure
that we should say that it doesn't
depend on the state of the weight so in
this case what we'll do is we'll take a
Hamiltonian which is unbounded from
above and below that said idealization
but find in most practical situations
and now we have this raising and
lowering operator and we want that we
commute with raising and lowering of the
weight all right and that gives us a
number of things what it means for
example is that many different paradigms
that people consider in thermodynamics
are equivalent to this one what we want
is that we have the broadest possible
definition of thermodynamics why do we
want that we want it because we want to
derive fundamental limitations on what
you can do and so we want to make sure
that we give the experimenter that most
the the most power possible and that way
we're guaranteed that if we we derive
some limitation then that limitation
will hold in anyone else as a definition
of thermodynamics all right
you also might want to consider more
restricted operations so for example you
can consider very crude control of your
system and actually even very crude
control at least in the classical case
is equivalent to this very strong
definition of thermodynamics that I've
been that I just presented where we
allow the experimenter to do everything
so it includes for example some people
say well you should just add in you're
only allowed you can't do a unitary you
can just stick in an interaction
Hamiltonian you
who's that it includes people that just
look at changing Hamiltonians it
includes paradigms where people have an
implicit battery in other words they
just say I do some unitary and all I
consider work to be the change in energy
of the system and bath so the we here
have an explicit battery in explicit
work system because we want to talk
about the physical quantum properties
perhaps of that battery but our paradigm
includes the implicit paradigm as well
which is what people do for example in
the stochastic thermodynamics community
and now having defined what we mean by
thermodynamics we can now ask the
questions alright so we've defined what
we mean by thermodynamics and now we can
ask what is the cost of the state
transformation and that is the second
law right it's telling us how much work
we need to do any particular state
transformation and when we say work we
could be many things by it often for
quantum systems little autonomous
machines there's no external work system
so you're dealing with the case where
there's no work we could imagine that
the amount of work we want to consider
is a deterministic amount of work
because we're dealing with quantum
systems and that's kind of a reasonable
thing to sometimes look at we may be
considering the average case and here
we're going to consider a fluctuating
work
good so now having defined
thermodynamics I want to derive the
kinds of second laws we can get the
kinds of restrictions on state
transformations so let me remind again
that in the classical case we have this
inequality the average work is is is
less than the change in free energy and
there's only one and it's only an
average case thing and here in the what
people found was that there in fact many
second laws if we go to finite size
quantum systems or finite size systems
in general and don't take that the man
term anomeric limit so let me first
present a kind of a toy model just a toy
thing of we called it sometimes
thermodynamic for children or noisy
operations the Hamiltonian is zero so
you're just dealing with the gibb state
is just a maximally mixed state and
you're just allowed to add the maximally
mixed state do a unitary and trace out
and what you can show is that you can go
from row to Sigma if and only if
row-major eise's Sigma all right
so an average is we know that it's just
the entropy that tells you whether you
can go from one state to another but for
in the finite size case its major we
find that as major ization which tells
you whether you can go from one state to
another and major ization is just that I
here we just only care about the
probability so I can just i order my
probabilities or my eigenvalues from
largest to smallest and then I look at
the sum of the K of sorry the L well
that should be L here I guess look at
the Eldar just the sum of L largest
probabilities I compare it to the L
largest probabilities of my target state
and if there if there if the sum of the
probabilities or the eigenvalues is
greater for the initial state than it is
for the final state for all values of
these sums then we say that row-major
eise's Sigma and we can think about that
graphically so here we plot the
probabilities P 1 Q 1 in non decreasing
in decreasing order stories or P 1 Q 1 P
2 Q 2 and now we can integrate so we
now look at the some of the largest
eigenvalues and here is the sum of the
first two largest eigenvalues in the sum
of the next three largest the three
largest eigenvalues in the sum of the
four largest eigenvalues and major
ization is represented graphically is
just that the curve of the initial state
is above is always above the curve of
the final state
alright so nice that a graphical
interpretation and that just corresponds
to double to that that discourse wants
in fact that in noisy operations you it
can go from Rho 2 Sigma if and only if
your map is doubly stochastic okay
now let's go to the case where we are no
longer doing thermodynamics for children
but have some energy levels and it's
also given by a slightly different form
of major ization what you do is instead
of ordering the eigen the probabilities
or the eigen values from largest to
smallest you you put in a inverse
Gibbs factor and then you order them
from largest to smallest in terms of
these combined quantities here we call
that beta ordering and now for each of
these and now what you do is you just
pluck the you order them and and there
and the ordering now corresponds to a
slope so you can see that the slope is
getting smaller and smaller so we plot
these in terms of their decreasing slope
along the x axis we plot the inverse
beta factor and here we plot the
probabilities and so once again we say
that we can go from row to Sigma if and
only if the curve the thermo major
ization curve of the initial state is
above that of the target state all right
so this is a generalization of the major
ization condition and it corresponds to
Joanna's is called this Gibbs
stochasticity because instead of being
doubly stochastic you know the row sum
to 1 but the columns have to sum to give
you back the Gibbs state rights like
Gibbs preserving
and now that what we're going to do is
we're going to generalize this notion of
Gibbs stochasticity to the case of
fluctuating word in the I shall also say
that in the if you allow deterministic
work then you're allowed to basically
move points to the left and we'll see
that later ok so I will derive this for
you but now take it take it as is so the
one of the results we derive this
classical result is that we can go from
row to Sigma in the case of fluctuating
work
if and only if this condition is met
it's like a generalization of Gibbs
stochastic or in the further
generalization of major ization so in
addition to having preserving the Gibb
state the thermal stage you also have
this additional term W here which also
is allowed to fluctuate and in some
sense helps you it's assisted mate helps
you achieve your goal of going from Rho
2 Sigma so it's this so so this is the I
guess the main set of equations we
derive and notice this top one here we
have the equation so for one for each
one for each level in our system and
what that means is that the certain and
the the quality that people had derived
in stochastic terminan determine that
makes like the joys in ski equation
there
in fact this gives you a lot more
constraints so it tells you all the
constraints that you have it's a
necessary and sufficient condition
giving you all the constraints you need
to go from Rho 2 Sigma
let me now show that from this it's just
a two-second derivation by just tracing
out some information to get the second
law equality all right so what we're
going to do is we're going to define
remember the free-energy was the the
free-energy was the average energy minus
T times s we're going to define a find
grain version of that and this fine
grain version if we average it it's
gonna give us the standard free energy
but here it's going to appear in the
exponent so what we do is we take our
generalization of double sarcastically
and all we do is we we multiply and
divide it by P of s the probability of
being at the initial state being in
state s multiplied by the probability on
both sides of the final state public
distribution and now take the sum over
all s Prime all right and if we do that
and we use so we've just always done is
we taken this doubly stochastic
condition here multiply it by this thing
here and take in the Sun and if we do
that we just use Bayes theorem and we
get the second law equality over here
all right and this second law equality
it's it's appeared in the literature
before in terms of people derived it
assuming some kind of stochastic
processes or performing measurements so
a classical derivations here we have it
we're able to get a fully quantum
derivation of the second law equality
and notice what's nice about it is that
we it gives us corrections to the second
law so we can take the second law
equality we can Taylor expand it and so
the first order we get this the first
term only and that's just the standard
second law but we also if we take n odd
we get these higher order Corrections to
in terms of beta the higher order
Corrections to the second law so it's a
more precise version
of the ordinary second law inequality
good so now let's go back to the case of
land our eraser which we had at the
beginning so this is Landau eraser and
there's four possibilities in a
deterministic case initially the bit is
in the zero or one state it has probably
half of being in either we don't know
which and what we want to do is we want
to bring it to the zero state so we want
to bring it here
and we have some probability of failure
all right now of course you can also
consider non-deterministic processes
where the work doesn't depend on whether
you go in so here we have a different
amount of work depending on whether you
were going from 0 to 0 or 0 to 1 or 1 to
0 or 1 to 1 but you can imagine that you
have a non-deterministic amount of work
for Landau erasure it doesn't matter it
turns out to be equivalent to what I'm
gonna say here if you look at our Gibbs
stochastic condition you get these two
conditions here and in the case of
perfect erasure
we can plot the we can plot the work
going from 0 0 with the average case and
what we find two things one is that we
only are able to achieve KT log two in
the case where both work values are KT
log two okay so we can only approach the
ideal cost of landau eraser on average
when there's no fluctuations whatsoever
in the amount of work that we have and
what's more we see that the work the
work can never get positive it's always
negative
so there's no way even if you invest a
bit more work in certain cases there's
no way to have it so that you sometimes
erase a bit and occasionally get work
out so the so using this relation we get
a few we get some additional insight
into landau erasure okay and that's why
these were able to show that these three
things are part of the reason that we
can't get perfect to ratio you can see
that in the case where there's the
failure probability goes to zero we have
to allow arbitrary large fluctuations in
work when we fail all right so the work
fluctuations have to be arbitrary large
if we want to be able to erase perfect
okay so just to review and we have
different kinds of major ization x' and
maps in the case we have no Hamiltonian
you just some operations correspond to W
stochastic maps if you have a
Hamiltonian you have Gibbs stochastic
maps and in the case of fluctuating work
you get those and generalized Gibbs
stochasticity
of course from a diagrammatic point of
view just like in the case of thermo
major ization and major ization in the
case when the work is just a difference
of two quantities what it corresponds to
is that we want to we want say the the
red curve here the initial state to
thermo major eyes the target state Sigma
so you want the red curve to be above
the green curve it's not so we can ask
how much work do we need to make this
transition happen and in the case of
fluctuating work in this case what
you're allowed to do is move the point
to the left and right and the amount by
which you scale these these points this
diagram corresponds to how much
fluctuating work you have to invest or
get out
so what we're gonna do we can derive
these classically but we're gonna do is
we're gonna drive it from a fully
quantum identity and that's the fully
quantum identity here it looks it
actually should look like the its this
is a Quantic and of it looks as a
similar form at least formally like the
Gibbs stochastic the generalized Gibbs
stochastic condition alright so and you
remember that we had this thing called
the fine grain free net free energy so
instead of the average the free energy
which is an average quantity we had this
fine grain free energy which was a
different quantity for each energy level
and on average it gave us the ordinary
free energy well here we have an
operator it's some kind of a map which
acts on our state rose so you have a
state row you apply this map which is an
we hit row by an exponential on both
sides with the beta H and that is kind
of an operator version of the
exponential of the free energy and with
that definition we're able to now here
we have the thermal operations with a
thermo operations gamma here we act a
unitary on the system and bath and trait
at the bath that's the thermal operation
here and so you have a free energy
thermal operation an inverse free energy
and that has to equal one alright and
now taking this point of my identity we
can look at what happens if the initial
state is classical we don't need the
final state to be just the initial state
has to be classical if the initial state
is classical then we recover we recover
the classical Gibbs
stochastic condition and we do that just
by imagining that the initial state we
can just write it out in terms of its
eigenvectors it's it's a diagonal in the
energy basis and if we do that then this
thermal this thermal operation gamma it
be just becomes a conditional
probability distribution right so in the
classical case we recover the Gibbs
sarcastic condition
I should also say that about a week or
two let me give you these ones there's a
there's a I'll get two moments some
other kind of quantum identities called
like a quantum crooks relation which
Johanna Berg found about the same time
as our heroine in fact a week a week or
so before
so let me kind of briefly go over the
proof of the quantum identity what I
want to do is I have my work system here
my state here and now what I want to do
is I want to act this kind of map which
looks like the free energy which kind of
converts this to a free energy and
ecstasy operator I want to add my
thermal operations and I want to then
close it off by acting the inverse of
that map and all I really do is I write
out I'm just good this proof relies on
very simple things it's just each line
is just a different property of thermal
operations so here the property we use
is that a thermal operation is just a
unitary and I'm adding the Gibbs State
as a unitary acting on the Gibbs state
in the system and wait here we use the
fact that here's just a rewriting of the
above equation then we use the fact that
the unitary conserves energy so we can
commute this thing through the unitary
so this map that is the free energy
commutes through the unitary and finally
we use a fact that a thermal operation
or a unit any unitary which is
translation invariant on the weight
preserves the identity so we just use
the many things we just use a free a few
simple properties of the of the of
thermo operations
and that lets a derive this fully
quantum identity called as generalized
Gibbs a quantum version of the
generalized Gibbs stochastic equation
you can write you can easily derive
quantum identities which formally at
least look like the second law equality
look like a jersey in ski equation
looked like a crooks equation and this
is your hand derived a crooks equation
and this equation which is only on the
weight here we're able to derive a
crooks equation which is on system and
weight as far as we can tell these
results are non-overlapping they don't
neither one implies the other and it's a
nice the crooks equation is nice written
in this form especially if you're
interested in the pets recovery map and
I know some of you are I'm interests in
the pets recovery map and what the
crooks equation basically is telling you
is that a thermodynamic process if we
look at the it's it's equal to the so if
we look at the dual of the inverse
thermal process it's equal to the pets
recovery map I don't know what that
means it seems like a deep fact about
the resource theory but it's quite
intriguing that we get that so the
reverse oh the dual of the reverse
thermodynamic process is the pets
recovery map of the thermodynamic
process
now if we take these different quantum
identities and go to the classical limit
imagine the initial state is classical
here's where we get these classical
equality so we get a second the second
law equality which I really presented we
get something which is a generalization
of the Jerez insky equation which is
valid and not just if the state is
thermal or if you perform a measurement
again this is appeared in the literature
but I think under only classical proofs
and we get a kind of a version of the
Crookes equation
how much time do I have another sorry I
have 15 minutes amazing
you sure okay I'll go to town
okay so let me discuss kind of where the
future directions and open questions so
I guess the thing here I want to
emphasize here is is what are the tools
from quantum information theory that we
can apply to thermodynamics I think
that's what I liked about John
pressfield's tutorial he was able to
point to different tools that we have in
quantum information theory and show how
they were useful in high energy physics
so let me talk about some of the things
that kind of tools we have in quantum
information theory and see how we can
apply them in the thermal every case so
the first thing and I'll I might looks
like I'll have a bit of time to discuss
this in more detail we can talk about in
not only fluctuations of work which is
something that was considered in the
stochastic thermodynamics community but
also fluctuations of states and this was
done in in kind of the late 1990s by
Bedell and Jonathan plenty oh who looked
at probabilistic transformations under
LOC C for quantum states and we can use
some of those results or adapt them in
order to understand fluctuations of
states you can ask what is the
probability of going from one state row
to one state Sigma we can also consider
different versions of the third law so
in computer science we're used to
considering time as a resource and the
third law in some sense the second law
tells you can I go from some Sacro to
some state Sigma and the third law is
effectively saying how much time does it
cost or what are the other resources
that it takes to go from row to Sigma so
like a Turing machine you can consider a
thermal machine so just like we make a
physical version of this of this thermal
device and then ask how many steps it
takes to say cool down the system so we
have those tools from computer science
in order to understand the time it takes
for the number of steps it takes to do a
particular transformation one can ask
about different resources so here we
even wolf look at you
finite sized dimension heat bath and
looked at cooling or erasure in that
case here we're able to look at infinite
dimensional heat paths and show that you
get a third law where you wear which
depend on the work fluctuations as I
mentioned that you need you need
arbitrary large work fluctuations in
order to cool something and you need
arbitrary large volume in order to cool
something
and so let's go to probabilistic
transformations under yeah sure
you don't have a way to recover to which
state you went to right or perhaps you
do because otherwise it just that you
know you go to their convex combination
it's not that there's no state that
you're unless you know where you are
going to then you just go to their
convex combination there's no one state
which you can say that you went to right
so you can consider two cases one is
that you have what we call the heralded
case or get out which is something to
get out of or essence looked at where
you imagine that I have a state and I
want to go to one of two states with a
with a label attached to it so I know
which one I have
I might imagine that or I could imagine
just that I want to go to some convex
combination of two states and I want to
maximize the probability in front of the
other one
or I could imagine that I want to go to
a state which is the largest fidelity to
a target state I'm interested in so it
may be that I'm not so you let me maybe
pose the question like this a bit more
generally so let's say that I can go
from some state row to some state Sigma
using an amount of work W and now I'm
gonna say I'm not gonna let you use that
W because you don't have a work system
so I quantify the amount of work so I
can go from Road to Sigma if I have some
work but if I don't have work can I go
there and the answer is no you can't but
maybe you can go there with some
fidelity or with some probability so
here we're choosing a rather arbitrary
measure we're saying that we're going to
what we want to do is you want to go to
some state which we can write in some
convex decomposition of the target state
and some arbitrary state and we're
interested in maximizing the probability
of going there there's other measures
you can choose and the fidelity is the
kind of a natural one as well so there's
a number of different measures you can
choose and I'm not sure what the best
one is we did this what we did this way
because we get a nice you can kind of
solve it fairly using some tools from
entanglement theory but the kind of
question of can I get close in fidelity
to the state if I don't have enough work
that's kind of a harder question but you
can probably use similar tools to get
that so I think that's an open question
as to how
you should how you should think of
approximately going to a state okay
thank you
so here we want to go to some state we
want to maximize the probability in the
sense we can think of the heralded case
with the unheralded case but here I'm
just gonna talk about the unheralded
case we just want that we can go to some
state which has as large a possible P
star to Sigma and I think what's nice
about this result is that we're able to
what we do were able to get bounds on P
star which are in terms of the work
costs so the greater the work cost the
the smaller the probability of getting
to your target state and in fact the
probability P star is bounded from below
by the work cost going from road to
Sigma and bounded from above by the
reverse process of going from Sigma to
row in the classical limit if I take the
thermodynamic limit where I go too many
copies then then this just goes to zero
so in the classical limit if you if it
costs you work and the thermal limit
because you work to go from some state
row to some state Sigma then there's
just that probably going there
probablistic Li is zero okay so what's
nice here is that you kind of in the
case of a finite size system you can do
that and the idea as follows let us take
as a measure these VLS they're just
basically that kind of like their little
major is eight they're kind of the sum
of the the l largest probabilities right
so they're kind of a measure for on
major as a major ization so here i'm
just gonna set that the total energy to
the hamiltonian to be trivial so i some
the l largest probabilities and i get
these measures VL and P star turns out
to be equal to the minimum of the ratio
right so for example if I want to go
from B to a sorry from A to B then what
I should look at is these different
ratios of the
vertical drop between my initial state
and the final state and that's because
what's happening here for probabilistic
transformation is that I'm allowed to
change my major ization curve by just
multiplying it by some probability and I
can drop I can drop the final state by
scaling it by an amount P right so the
probability the fluctuation is just
given by the largest distance between
the two curves and the work is given by
the vertical distance between the two
curves so in terms of how much work is
required to go from B to A or A to B
it's just given by these the smallest
ratios here and so this graphically
allows you to in some sense bound the
probability of a transformation by the
these vertical distances here joe-joe is
called the sub major ization and he's
noted that this this kind of version of
major ization just corresponds to the
question is there a subsonic matrix
which satisfies these conditions here so
again another kind of generalization of
major ization
likewise using this notion that the
fluctuations in sometimes if we have a
if we're trying to physically do a
process and the fluctuations grow very
large then it becomes harder and harder
to do a process if the fluctuations in
work become larger and larger right so
the heat theorem originally given by
Planck in 1911 says that when the
temperature of a pure substance
approaches absolute zero its entropy
approaches zero the heat theorem it has
nothing to do with thermodynamics as you
will see it just basically is the
statement that the ground state should
be non degenerate so that has nothing to
do with Hermann dynamics but to the
Hamiltonian the unattainable T principle
on the other hand which Nernst formated
in 1912 says that any thermal process
cannot attain absolute zero and a finite
number of steps or within a finite time
and what we want to do is we want to
quantify this and it turns out we can
quantify it in terms of the in terms of
the amount of work and how it fluctuates
and in terms of the volume of the heat
bath
so let me end just by mentioning a few
other kind of areas of a kind of
interest so I mentioned that somehow
these quantum crooks relation that your
hand gets and that we get it looks like
it's a statement about the pets recovery
map and it's kind of interesting to kind
of dig further into that and and get a
better sense of what that means and
whether we can use some of our insights
and to say approximate recover ability
to understand thermodynamics in better
detail there's also the question of what
a cyclic process is and that's something
that's also not resolved in
thermodynamics in the macroscopic limit
we you know if you remember the
classical statement of the second law it
was a that heat can never pass from a
hotter body to a colder body or a colder
body to a hundred body without some
other change occurring elsewhere what do
we mean by no other change occurring
classically you might think it means
that that it should approximately be
cyclic but we know from embezzling of
quantum states that that that that's not
going to work all right
and if you demand that something be
approximately cyclic you can always find
a sum and Sylla where you are
approximately cyclic on that until you
get you get arbitrarily close from its
final state to its initial state and yet
you can extract some work from it just
like in the entanglement embezzling we
go from some state to another state
which is arbitrary close to its initial
state and we get entanglement from it so
there seems to be an embezzling problem
in thermodynamics and it makes it almost
impossible to define what we mean by a
cyclic process so that is I think an
interesting open problem and without I'd
like to thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan we have time for
questions I see one over there
so you put out the broadest set that is
allowed in the math of economics that
allows the the most powerful scheme that
possible and but in that scheme still
you think about the unitary that
commutes with the total Hamiltonian and
if you know the initial state and if you
think about the unitary on conserves the
average energy on the average energy
given that interest state and that would
give you like more powerful like
operation like yes so is there a reason
why you only yeah you stick to the
community in condition yeah in sometimes
because you you know the the you oh you
don't conserve energy on average you can
serve it exactly right so in an actual
system you can serve it exactly so if
you're doing a operation which only
conserves energy on average it means
that you are secretly smuggling in a
little system which sometimes takes
energy and sometimes doesn't take energy
but on average doesn't and the amount of
fluctuations that you're putting into
that have to be arbitrarily large so
you're you're cheating a little bit when
you're looking at when you just say that
you only want to consider work on
average it means that you've smuggled in
your system now I don't mind that if you
want to have your system there which
sometimes has work and sometimes doesn't
but I want you to account for it because
I want to make everything you know all
these kinds of abstract notions like
conserving on average I want to make
sure that we understand physically
what's going on and so in that case I'll
have this secret device which is taking
on fluctuations arbitrary large in fact
it in some sense here I can consider it
just by you know my work system here is
allowed to fluctuate and I might care
about the work only on average and then
I effectively get the paradigm where I
only conserve energy on average
so in your scheme still like your
battery the acceptor work fraps rates
right the work I mean you could in this
paradigm you can consider what so here
it's just a paradigm of what we mean by
thermodynamics the quantities you want
to consider are up to you you may be
interested in the average work in which
case really in some sense you're
conserving work on how you're conserving
energy it's equivalent to thinking about
conserving energy on average but it's a
bit more honest because you see how big
the fluctuations have to be on the other
hand you could also look at the
deterministic work cost within this
framework because you're just basically
picking a different distribution of the
kind of work you're interested in thank
you any other question um I was
wondering if any of these free energy
change in free energy results that
you're talking about can be easily
extended to holography through their
usage of the muscle of the modular
hamiltonian yeah so I actually have a
work in progress with the Rob Myers in
Perimeter Institute and some of his
postdocs where we're looking at can we
take these additional second laws and
apply them to blackhole systems or to
gravitational system so we know that for
black holes you have the second law of
thermodynamics and if you if you ask
what that means in terms of the black
holes that the area has to always be
increasing and now you know that these
other laws of thermodynamics also have
to hold and you can ask if they have
what the physical interpretation is on
the gravity side now it's difficult to
answer that question we tried a bit
thinking in terms of quasi normal modes
of a black hole or because you hear
these applied out of equilibrium systems
so you can imagine an out of equilibrium
black hole it turns out that that's you
know difficult to see if that works at
the moment we're using it we're doing it
we're doing the computation in the
context of a DST ft because they're in
the CFT you know that these second laws
have to apply and you can ask
they must court you know according if
you believe in the correspondence then
they should correspond to something
happening on the gravitational side but
the computation actually is quite
difficult there was okay
I have a so I so the question is I'm
interested if there is some experimental
way of probing this higher order terms
and second laws that kind of you knew
how this kind of extension of second was
can be seen experimental in some
experiments yeah so I guess you know
what these tell you is that so normally
people will tell you well the entropy
let me use the entropy as an example
they would say the entropy has to
increase and that's what the second law
says but here we see we need these other
conditions as well and so it's possible
that some of these could be violated but
the entropy could still increase so they
give you additional constraints and you
might want to say can we see them in the
lab so for example it may be that the
largest eigenvalue gets higher but the
entropy still increases well that's
ruled out by by these additional second
laws so I guess you can you can never
show that they you can confirm that you
see them holding of course you can never
it's film it doesn't say that they're
never violated so you can't prove that
but you can least show that they provide
reasonable constraints any other
question yeah so you're using the keep
state as a free resource but more found
more fundamentally the keep state is
derived from the second law of
thermodynamics by maximizing the entropy
of an overall system and give a look at
the small system is there have you do
you do you have a comment towards that
or a derivation said of going from give
state to to your second law so so the
derivation that we had for the Gib
States so so we call it a zero with law
in some sense of of thermodynamics so
this is in the paper with Fernando
Brando in 2015 in in proceedings the
national kind of a science what we
claimed was the so let's go back to the
resource theory
I just said that you're allowed to add
some free state and we don't tell you
what it is and now you can ask what Free
State are you allowed if you allow any
state which is not the thermal state
then you can do everything the theory
becomes trivial because you can accept
an arbitrary large amount of work from
it so in some sense you are just
demanding that this resource theory be
done you know don't allow arbitrary
doesn't allow arbitrary work to be
extracted it's not trivial forces you to
make this free State the Gib state of a
single temperature so temperature
naturally arises from the resource
theoretic picture and in terms of you
know it's the equivalence class of
states you're allowed to add in the
resource theory such that the resource
theory is not trivial so that's how I
would frame the zeroth law and
temperature emerging it's not coming
from the second law it's just coming
from stability of your resource theory
okay I think our time is up
we have an awesome but before that let's
thank George again
you